[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
après l'époque du ballon j'ai cherché un
temps pas longmont puis j'ai quitté mon
salon pour bien voir ce que nous valons
alors j'ai posé des jalons dans son j'ai
pris du galon parlons peu cela mon bien
des rimes jusque dans les talons comme
un gentil egotrip j'ai trouvé comment
commencer plus de ballons les bras
ballants mais des histoires à balancer
qu'on pense ce qu'on pense pas j'ai mis
des phrases en condensé co dansokho
danse pas je fais tout ça pour compenser
alors une passion à palier c'est pas ça
pour peut pas nier jacques c'était par
paliers de ne plus mettre des paniers je
me suis plus derrière la ligne à trois
points et ses intentions je suis devant
les interlignes gym et trois mois de
suspension
j'ai pris la 6 d'abord un bon
[Musique]
j'ai pris la syllabe au wagon
j'ai mis des shoots ouverts des
lancers-francs d'adjectifs jimmy toute
ma verve tout ça est très addictif
je suis en phase offensive et la
démarche évolué chercher des passes
décisives de musiciens reconnus
j'ai frappé les assommant ces tribus et
chaque terminaison j'ai réalisé ma
chance pourtant je suis qu'à mi saison
j'ai pas eu peur du contre et j'ai ce
match et on les vit quand on lis bien
slam dunk le parallèle est évident pour
pas fait une statue à la mi temps je
teins statut d'intermittent un termite
aux intermittents intersites en
déversant dans le money time et excitant
qui croient jusqu'au dernier quart temps
et a distant mais persistant je joue la
rime à chaque instant j'ai pris là si
lavaur
[Musique]
j'ai pris la 6 dabo vraiment
j'ai voulu transposer pour que le match
devait massène la pression a explosé
comme de drogue jamais malsaine je me
suis exposé pour que le public devienne
jury c'est fort et c'est un danger comme
un shoot de stephen curry ste public à
lui seul que revient le droit de marc
pitre et quand il qu'ils font quand ils
gueulent pas moyen de m'abriter immobile
ou bondissant qu'il me clash ou qu'ils
me donnent cet âge ils essaient puissant
comme un smatch d'albums en moins de
vingt-quatre secondes je dois tirer mon
couplet et si jamais le couple est le
bonheur sera complet je propose des
verres un peu visage le micro dans le
viseur poseur de textes un peu bazar
j'aime bien reprend au buzzer j'écris
massina vos romans
[Musique]
j'ai pris la silla beauvois bon
j'ai pris là s'il a beau avoir à bord à
bord
j'ai pris la syllabe aux abords
prétendre à bord
pour ta vie' ses métiers
[Applaudissements]
à la guitare olivier
aux percussions feedback
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai pris facile à votre banque
merci beaucoup merci
opel
[Applaudissements]